[Music]  you know they say we see everything once  in this cake  pretty sure we've seen they think this  need help  you all right i'm fine  the bad news is it's inoperable and  never start your radiation  [Music]  what's going on with you  i want to know that there's meaning in  the things i do  if you're watching this i'm probably  trying to convince you of something  pretty unbelievable or  i'm dead  don't do anything to get her back but  this is i mean the next dose could kill  you  they're things that are far worse  than death  [Music]  what happened to him  they're not returning  it's got to be me you can't deal with  reality  the clock keeps ticking down  the time is an illusion  you